so one cowboy hat the whole timer in San
Antonio the guy in front row I know he
was cool-looking too huh
yeah if you can pull a cowboy hat off
you can pull a cowboy half Luke Luke
Rockhold can fall for cowboy hat it's
hardly the surfer no he pulls one off
nowadays I've seen pictures haven't me
did this really he's a good-looking dude
but it's just that natural to him no
you'll be a natural oh no you mean this
last Instagram post Brian I swear to God
I know I'm funny just you I mean
definitely follow him let me see
Luke Rockhold that's your friend you can
I love him I will follow him now I don't
follow Luke you get posted videos
together hold on hold on okay I swear I
didn't see this I haven't looked at my
Instagram
that's so funny that's his is that
really his first yeah there's a snake in
my butt hmm that's what I think
I don't follow he's a cowboy I know
that's really weird crazy inconvenient
huh what is that a pack of cigarettes
can't tell
looks like alcohol or cigarettes it you
still talk to my come on time what it's
not to lose all tidy um
he's done fighting you're following
hiiii fallen bro please Hannah you're
falling oh I didn't see that
that's hilarious I just I was thinking
about I said I saw a picture of him I
think on polar I swear to God I didn't
see it no I'm not lying I that's just a
crazy coincidence but he he did a polo
out of something or maybe it was carlos
condit who did it
he looks good with a cowboy hat on too
no I swear I really didn't I don't think
I'm following him dude New York am i
yeah cat just confirmed it yeah how do
you how do you find out where you go to
who you're following it says the Luke
Rockhold yep you're only following 59
people so gentlemen it's pretty easy
it's pretty easy to follow and then go
and a Luke and then it's Luke Rockhold
and if you scroll through you'll see
that you can't see any pictures so if
you can find that picture on my it's
possible to follow somebody and not see
their pictures all right no you can get
their notifications never muted or
accidentally not unfollow crystally
either that was mine no you follow Luke
right there see followers Luke Rockhold
oh damn it get young whoops
bury you probably just saw me cowboy oh
no hi yeah I saw him once but I'm not
not this but it's just funny that's
history this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah
yeah he looks good looks getting
anything on huh I'm glad we solved that
case that you followed - good-good
intensive work cat
yeah thanks it work good intensive work
I'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]